oh yeah we got to do the afghanistan war
this is this is this is a tribute to the
this is a tribute to the afghanistan war
my first war
and i never thought i'd feel this way
far as i'm concerned i'm glad i got
the chance to say
that i do believe i love you taliban
and if i should ever go away
the rocky shows the skies are grey
your [ __ ] kids have your
bed post i read that in an article if
you can remember me
keep smiling keep shining
21 years
war it's a just war
to help the pedophile warlords
we grow opium for vicodin
oxycontin tastes so good
for sure especially when it's grown by
pedophile
warlords
nothing grows but opium and boys
in afghanistan bin laden
wasn't even there but who cares
you people have cool hair
the pashtuns i think they were involved
i forget
[Music]
it went kaboom
and then we saw a group of
pedophile warlords growing opium instead
we said keep smiling
keep shining you're gonna have a
democracy
so you can
for kids and grow
up for the drug addicts who live in our
country
and lithium ion
[Music]
so that our pedophiles can look up
porn
it's about heroin and pedophilia
that's the entire foreign policy of our
country
it's about heroin and pedophilia
that's what aliens would say if they
looked at
history it's kind of amazing they go
all they ever did was [ __ ] kids and get
high
they could have done so much other [ __ ]
but they didn't
[Music]
never even happened
the towers are still there
[Music]
and now biden says we are not
going there anymore
we're bringing the pedophile warlords
to america you can come to america now
welcome bring your heroine
we've got boys welcome to america says
president biden
you can [ __ ] kids and grow heroin here
ask everyone their pronouns it's been 21
years
of creating chaos in hell for financial
gain
thank you for everything we love you
and we hope you love us here's to 21
more years of hell
take that pill it'll make you feel
better
and don't worry we'll be back we always
come back
we'll be back but until we do
we love you so that's our
that's our um that is our uh
montage and our tribute to uh
afghanistan and a just and beautiful war